A Porsche with a hybrid system!
And a Porsche with four seats!
The Panamera has already dished out its share
of surprises for sports car fans.
Now, for the second generation, the Panamera
4 plug-in E-hybrid has been joined by another
with 500 kilowatts of system power.
But for today, we'll stick with the less powerful
plug-in-hybrid.
Its electric motor and 243-kilowatt V6 gasoline
engine add up to a total system power of 340 kilowatts.
Fuel consumption is rated at just 2.5
liters per 100 kilometers, but only as long
as the driver resists the temptation to really step on it.
Our tester Reinhold Deisenhofer points out
that, since the Panamera E-hybrid weighs 2.2 tons,
it takes some power to push that weight
from zero to 100 kilometers per hour in just
five seconds, but the system has a good 700
newtonmeters of torque.
The Normal drive mode recharges the battery
on the go, and then there are the Sport and
Sportplus modes.
In all three, the overboost function temporarily
steps up the boost pressure for the pick-up
typical of Porsche.
As in most hybrids, the display can show the
energy flow at any time.
A Porsche is a Porsche is a Porsche.
The design has spoken the same easily recognizeable
language for decades, and the Panamera is
no exception.
The E-hybrid differs from the 4-seater's gasoline-powered version only in small details - such as the
green-rimmed badging and the green brake calipers.
The Panamera 4 E-hybrid is 5 meters and 5
centimeters long.
The longer executive body style is available
on request.
Tucked under the front hood is the V6 with
2.9 liters capacity.
Reinhold Deisenhofer realizes that, with a
Porsche, sound is always a factor.
In all-electric drive, the E-hybrid glides
over the asphalt on its air suspension in
almost total silence.
But if you really bring out the performance,
it sounds just like the Porsches we've always known.
The Panamera E-hybrid pounces from 80 to 120
kilometers per hour in just 3.1 seconds
- only a fraction of a second slower than
other Panamera variants - because of the few
hundred extra kilos the battery adds.
Reinhold explains that it takes
about 6 hours to fully recharge the e-hybrid's
battery from a European 220-volt household
outlet.
A quick-charge station for an extra four and
a half thousand euros will cut two hours off
that time.
The Panamera E-hybrid's competitors are the
Mercedes Benz S500 and the BMW 7 seriesr as plug-in-hybrids,
but in the family of Panameras, the Porsche e-Hybrid is actually the lowest priced of them all.